I try to wake up every morning and get
several hours of writing done before I
go to the hospital
which can range between 5:00 in the
morning and 7:00 in the morning so I
could in theory be writing as early as
3:00 do a few hours of writing see my
patients during the day
and intermittently during the day I do
some phone interviews if I'm on call at
the hospital I can write a bioethics
column and then I come home and do
probably a couple of hours of bioethics
work in the evening
sure well until recently I was teaching
bioethics at Brown University and at NYU
so there I would have my full class from
either of undergraduate or graduate
students and I would do some consulting
work on the hospital floors as well now
since I'm practicing medicine nearly
full-time at Mount Sinai in psychiatry I
do occasional bioethics consult inside
the hospital at Mount Sinai but far more
often I'm consulting people outside
giving them advice on issues relating to
the beginning of life the end of life
absolutely I think 30 years ago there
were no bioethicists it is one of the
new occupations of the technological age
that we live in and it takes traditional
moral questions about when life begins
when life ends and seeks them through
the prism of modern technologies and as
we've developed for example ways of
keeping life going beyond its natural
parameters the question arises how far
should we keep life going and a
bioethicists
inside the consulting setting of the
hospital doesn't offer people answers it
sets out parameters people to think
about answers so that a family on their
own can make decisions based upon
different ways other people have handled
these situations in the past
I think it's far better to think of Iowa
persistence guides I think there is a
cottage industry now of people who have
made a living or a career out of
criticizing bioethicists because they
view bioethicists makes platonic
Guardians on high who step into the fray
and say this is how we will do things I
know no professional bioethicists to
actually operate that way
far more bioethicists show people the
signpost show people the different
alternatives and let them make their own
decisions and I think that's important I
think that in the same way you wouldn't
want your medical or legal decisions
made by someone else you would want to
be consulted on an expert and then make
the decisions on your own
a bioethicists an expert who shows you
the different parameters and then lets
you make your own decision
I should add before the 1970s philosophy
as a field had branched far away from
moral thought it delved into questions
of epistemology the five-year-old's
age-old question when my parents leave
the room do they still exist and it's a
bioethics but in addition to working
inside the hospital with families has
also brought morality back into the
field philosophy